Good morning, class. Welcome to our
first class.
And today, what I want to do is provide
the framework
for how we will learn this semester.
What are we learning?
How are we learning? Why are we
learning?
All right. So,
this is a class of ideas.
So, it's really important for you to pay
attention and understand how these ideas
connect with each other. If I'm not
being clear,
ask me a question.
In fact, make it a habit to ask as many
questions as possible, because that way
you will learn more, learning will will
be more fun for you, and learning will
be much more clear to you, okay? So,
let's get in a habit of asking
questions. So, wherever I am
confusing, wherever I'm speaking too
fast, wherever you don't understand,
interrupt me. Okay? Let's get in a
habit. All right. So,
um
I first want to talk about
Immanuel
Kant.
We will we will be discussing a lot this
semester, because he is the greatest
philosopher
in Western history.
And he teaches us he taught us how the
world works. And this is what he told
us. He told us that
we can never know the objective reality.
There is an objective reality, what he
calls the noumena,
okay?
Or the things
in themselves.
That is not knowable to us. That's the
world we can never access.
Why? Because we perceive
the world through our senses.
Our senses, our perception, warps the
world and changes it into a structure
that we can process, called the
phenomena,
which are the things that appear to us.
Okay? So, the example is
time and space.
Time and space do not exist outside of
us.
Time and space do not exist in reality.
But, for us to understand reality, we
need to add in time and space.
Okay, that's the example.
All right?
So,
how the world works is we perceive the
world, we perceive the noumena, and turn
it into the phenomena for us to process.
In other words, and this is really
important,
reality is what we imagine
it
to be.
There is no objective reality.
Reality is what we imagine it to be.
Life is a constant process, a constant
act of imagination.
All right? That's
that's Immanuel Kant. That's the first
idea I want you to understand.
So, what I want I want to do in this
class this semester is train you, or
teach you, or inspire you
to
augment your imagination,
so that you see the world much more
clearly.
This class is not about what to think,
it's about how to think.
All right.
All right. So,
let me explain the structure of
the course.
So, there's past,
there's present,
and there's future.
We'll be looking at all three this
semester, the past, the present, and the
future. We will analyzing all three in
order to construct a more objective
reality for ourselves.
We will not succeed, we will fail.
But, the process of trying will train
our minds to think much more critically
about the world.
So, let me explain how.
In the present, we have geopolitics.
We'll be studying geopolitics.
For example, why is there war in
Ukraine? Why is there war in the Middle
East? What happened? We'll be studying
geopolitics.
And we'll try to understand why this is
happening. We'll try to formulate an
analytical model
of geopolitics.
Okay? An analytical model.
We will then use this analytical model
to make predictions
about the future.
Why do we do this?
Because these predictions
will tell us
if our analytical model is correct or
not.
Okay? Does that make sense? It's no
different from artificial intelligence.
How do you know if your artificial
intelligence the model is correct or
not? Well, you test it against reality.
Okay? There's no difference between that
artificial intelligence system and what
we're trying to do here.
And why are we doing this? Because
if we're able to have an analytical
model that makes correct predictions,
then we can take all this and go back
and analyze the past to un- to reveal
the secret history
of the world.
That is a project we are undertaking
this semester
to discover for ourselves the secret
history
of humanity.
Because you may not know this,
but all the history that you learn in
school, all that history that you think
you know,
it is false.
Okay? The history that you know, you the
history that you believe,
it is a system
implanted into your brains
by powerful people.
Okay? So, the real question that we're
looking at this semester is really how
does
power
work?
Because if we can if we can figure this
out, then you will achieve liberation.
You will achieve freedom. You will
understand how you're being manipulated
by others, and therefore you will be
free.
You'll be empowered
to live the way you want to live.
To see the world that is true to you.
So,
let me give you three concrete examples
of how power works.
Okay, the first example is money.
Let us do a thought experiment.
I'm a bank, okay? I decide I want to
open a bank.
And now you're allowed to put money in
the bank, okay? So, all of you get
together, and you put $5 million
in
in the bank.
Now, $5 million. Now, why do you put $5
million into my bank? Because I promise
you 1% interest.
Right? 1% interest.
That's a really good deal.
But, now because I owe you some money,
right? I owe you 1% interest, I now need
to go make money for myself.
So, I have a friend
who's building a restaurant, and he
says, "I need $5 million to build the
restaurant,
and after a year I will pay you back 10%
interest."
Okay?
10% interest.
And so, I make a 9% profit, and I can
use that to pay my employees, to put pay
myself a salary, to build a new
building, okay?
So, now I want you to think about this.
I'm the bank, I got $5 million in
deposit money, then I give out a $5
million $5 million loan.
Today, how much money is in the bank?
Countless. Hm? Countless.
How much money now do I have?
S- I got $5 million from you guys, then
I give it out to someone else.
Right? So, how much money is in the bank
right now?
Zero.
Zero is c- zero, right?
It should be zero.
Logically, the answer is zero. In fact,
zero is the answer that you are taught
in economics.
It's what you are taught, yeah? Zero is
not the answer that we're taught in
economics. Okay. You cannot loan all of
the money that you have. Like
for for example, if
they will have a limit like
like 25 percent, I don't know. Okay.
Maybe 10 percent. So, you can only loan
like 4 million dollars. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Really good point. Okay. Oh,
yes. Okay. So, that's really good. So,
in economics you learn about the idea of
the fractional reserve system.
Okay. What's fractional reserve? As you
say, you must leave behind
a certain amount of money. It could be 7
percent. It could be 10 percent. It
depends on the on the country, okay?
Let's say 10 percent.
So, theoretically, I can I I cannot
actually lend out 5 million dollars. I
can only lend out 4.5 million dollars.
Okay. You're right. Okay. That's that's
that's law as well.
Okay.
Um
Actually,
um Okay. Let's say I lend out 4 4.5
million dollars, okay? Now, how much
money do I have in the bank?
2.5 Yeah. Half a million, right? Okay.
So, again, this is what you're taught in
economics. This is what makes logical
sense, right?
The correct answer,
what actually happens in real life,
is
you have you now have 9.5
million dollars.
Okay. That is the correct answer.
This makes no sense, right?
But it happens in reality. And how do we
know? Because
over the past 20 years,
Chinese banks, like the Bank of China,
uh the Bank of Industry and Commerce,
the Agricultural Bank of China,
if you Google these banks, what you will
see is these past 20 years, these banks
have become the largest in the world.
How did that happen?
Was it because Chinese people got rich
and put all the money in the bank?
No, that's not what happened. What
happened, guys?
It's supported by the government.
The government.
Okay. What happened was these banks
start to lend money out to corporations,
to government, to people to
build skyscrapers, to build roads.
In other words, the banks start to
create money out of nothing
in order to finance China's
infrastructure projects.
And that's what banks are allowed to do.
They're allowed to print money,
create money out of nothing.
Okay. Does that make sense?
Now, the question then is
Wait a minute here.
That's an absurd. How this system come
into being? How was it created? Okay.
Well, actually, there's a very easy
explanation for where we got the system
from.
All right. So, let me explain the
history and the origin of the system.
So, in the beginning,
it was merchants who engaged
um in finance. Because merchants needed
money in order to facilitate trade.
Okay. And some merchants became
extremely wealthy. And when they became
very wealthy, they started banks in
order to support trade and other
merchants.
Okay. So,
um
these banks
traded in gold, because that was
the primary source and supply of money
back then.
Okay. So,
um what happened is
you would come and you would put your
money
your gold in the bank for safekeeping.
And the bank would give you a contract.
Right?
A contract is just saying, "Thank you
for giving me your gold. I promise to
give back your gold at any time
that you want it."
And this is what we call a receipt,
right?
And
this would allow for
better
and easier trade. Because now I can take
this contract and I can go to England,
okay? Maybe I'm based in Italy. But now
I can go to England and say, "Listen, I
need to buy cotton or bananas
from you." And the person is like,
"Well, what are you going to give me?"
I'm going to give you gold, right? So, I
take the receipt and I give it to you.
Right?
And why do we And why do we do this?
Because it's a lot easier than giving
gold to other people.
And so, this system would facilitate
trade
throughout the world.
Does that make sense?
Now, I'm the bank. I have all this gold
and I want to make money with it.
So, I want to give it to other people.
So, other merchants would come come to
me and say, "Listen, I need gold. Can
you lend me out gold?"
Right?
But
I say to him, "Yeah, but if I give you
out the gold, you have a security issue.
It's inconvenient for you. So, why don't
I give you a receipt, a contract
instead?"
Does that make sense?
Because all I need is a contract. All I
need is a receipt in order to go and do
trade elsewhere.
Right? So, so by doing this, what I've
done is I've doubled the gold
in my bank.
Right? I've created money out of
nothing.
So, the gold is still 5 million.
That hasn't changed. But the receipt is
now 5 million plus 5 million. So,
theoretically,
I now have 10 million in the bank.
All right?
So, that's how
money and finance works.
Now, there's a problem with this system.
What's the problem with the system?
What do you mean?
Um
why would they
Why would the other people say the
receipt has gold? That's the same value.
Okay. That's a good question, okay? Why
is it that people believe in me? Okay.
The answer is very simple. The answer is
because for most of human history,
people didn't need money.
If you if you were just a normal person,
what were you doing? Were you in a
village growing crops? If you wanted to
to like get new stuff, what would you
do? You would trade with someone else,
right?
Maybe maybe you have a goat that I want.
Well, then I would I would trade you a
cow for it. So, we didn't actually need
money.
So, for most of human history,
no one had any need for money. It was
only
in certain circumstances that you would
want money. So, for example, marriage,
right?
Okay. So, for most of human history,
money
represented
debt
that could unpaid.
Oh, sorry. Debt that could never be
repaid.
So, for example, a very common thing is
um maybe you and I fight.
And I kill you.
Well, in theory, your family should now
come and kill me.
But obviously, that would create a lot
of problems, right? So, the way to
settle the dispute is I would give your
family money.
Because money was symbolically meant to
say, "I'm sorry I killed you. This is a
debt that can never be repaid."
Okay. That's what money was used for in
most circumstances throughout human
history. There was no actually real use
for money. It was symbolic.
But with the rise of trade and with
merchants, they needed money in order to
facilitate the trade.
But these merchants all knew each other.
So, they trusted each other anyway. So,
money was a mechanism for them to
um
trade easier, okay? Does that make
sense?
All right.
Okay. So, let's go back to the question.
This system looks great. I can print
money out of nothing. But there's a
problem with this system. What is the
problem?
There's a problem here.
What was the trade?
Hm? I think you can forge the receipts,
the money fakes.
Okay. That's actually a good question,
okay? So, yeah, is it possible to forge
the contract? Okay.
So, um that's a really good point. The
problem is
uh so, the
the answer is that they all knew each
other anyway.
Okay. Because it's a very small circle.
Again, we have not reached the modern
period where um it's a lot of people
using money. If that's the case, then
forging becomes a problem. We'll discuss
this in future classes, okay?
Counterfeiting. But at this point in
history, forging is actually not a big
issue. There's actually a bigger issue.
And there's a huge issue.
What's the issue?
I have 5 million dollars of gold, right?
There's about 10 million dollars
of gold out there
in receipts.
What's the problem with that?
The problem is that if everyone wants
the gold at the same time,
I go bankrupt, right? Because I lose my
reputation. The contract says that at
any time you want the gold, I must give
it to you.
But if I have like if there's a hundred
million dollars
in gold contracts, but I only have 10
in gold, only if
15 million
wants the gold back, then I'm screwed.
If this is what we call a bank run.
Okay? A bank run.
And this is a huge problem for
merchants.
Okay?
There's also another problem with the
system. And the problem is this.
Who do I usually lend my money to? Do
you guys know? If I'm a bank, if I'm a
merchant, who do I usually lend my money
to?
Okay, guys. Um today we lend the money
to entrepreneurs. But back then, there
really weren't entrepreneurs. There were
kings
and noble people. And what do they do
all the time? What do they do with
money?
To fight wars. Okay?
That's why that's why there's a demand
for gold. Because if I'm a king, I need
to fight a war. Usually against my
brother or someone else to control this
territory.
Right? Now, the problem with this is I
could get killed, in which case, oops.
But also, and what's much more common is
the king would be like, "Screw you,
bank. I don't need to pay you back."
Okay? So, there's actually a lot of risk
with this system. So, over time, they
developed a system to mitigate or reduce
this risk.
Okay? What would they do? What What they
would do is they would create cartels.
Cartels are just partnerships. So, maybe
this bank works with another bank, works
with another bank throughout Europe.
They And the way they establish these
cartels is usually through
intermarriage, right? They would marry
each other.
Um they would combine together. And that
way,
let's say let's say
15 million uh
of receipts wants back the gold, but
there's only 10 million. Well, guess
what? You just go to another bank.
Okay?
And let's just say a king
decides, "I'm not going to pay you back,
bank." Well, your bank works with other
banks to establish a new enemy to kill
the king to get the money back.
Do you understand?
And this system is what we call today
central banking.
And what you will learn in this class is
central banking controls the world
today.
Okay?
Now, what's really important about this
system is
that it's based on power.
Right? And what power is you can turn
nothing money
the contract into everything.
Okay? That's what money is.
Okay. So, we live in a world in which
banks can print out
money, right? So, now let's ask
ourselves a question.
Wait a minute here.
If the banks can print as much money as
possible,
why do we have poverty?
Right?
Because we can just give money to poor
people and they won't be poor anymore.
Why do we have poverty?
If there's all the food in the world
that we want, why are people starving
still?
Why?
Because we don't have limited
money resources.
Okay. So, we don't have limited
resources. We have scarcity, okay?
Right. So, that is the common answer,
scarcity. We have poverty because of
scarcity.
But I already told you this. They can
print money out of nothing.
So, money is infinite.
Money is an infinite resource.
So, why are we Why do we have poor
people then?
That's kind of strange.
Well,
like money are only
just, you know,
used for trade. They still have limited
resources and, you know, the actual need
like
the the actual needs Okay. You You You
You see what's happening is this. You
all believe money is scarce, okay?
But I just spent the past 10, 20 minutes
explaining to you it's not scarce. It's
infinite. You see, it's just a number.
We can at any time print out as much
money as we need.
Okay? So, that's how power works. Power
has brainwashed you into thinking
something that is not true.
You've been taught from the first day
that money is scarce.
But it's not scarce. It's infinite.
And no matter what I say to you, you
still believe this, okay?
So, you have to get that out of your
head. Money is not scarce, it is
infinite. So, let's go back to the
question. Why is there poverty in this
world? Why do people starve?
Why is there inequality in this world?
Why are there poor people? Why are there
rich people? What's the answer?
Because they don't print infinite money.
Okay.
Because it's scarce. I can So, guys,
this is amazing, okay? You guys can't
get out of your head. You think money is
scarce. You think it is not possible to
print infinite money, when I already
told you it is possible to print
infinite money, because they do this all
the time. Yeah?
Uh the one who has the power don't want
everyone to share the same
Yeah.
Because we don't want people to all have
money.
The powerful people don't want that.
That's exactly the answer. And you And
why? Because
otherwise, no one would work.
Do you understand?
The point of putting money is not to
give you money. The point of putting
money is to create the illusion
that money is valuable and therefore you
will work hard in order to obtain it.
But in order for me to make you want to
get money, I need to create artificial
misery.
Do you understand?
Right? If there weren't poor people, you
wouldn't want to be rich.
It's only because you see people suffer
that you would want to go make money for
yourself.
Your What do your parents tell you? Your
parents tell you, "Work hard in school.
Make a lot of money. Otherwise, you're
going to end up like a poor person."
Right? Well, guess what? If there are no
poor people, your parents couldn't say
that to you.
And you wouldn't want to work hard in
school.
Right?
That's why we have poverty.
Because poverty creates the illusion
that money is valuable.
In other words,
poverty isn't what you do to yourself,
it is what the powerful do to you.
Now, let me ask you another question.
You guys have studied some economics?
Why do we have like crises?
Crises.
For example,
there's a stock market crash.
Or for example, the economy goes down
and people lose their jobs. Why do we
have crises?
I don't
Exactly. You're not taught this in
economics class.
That's kind of weird, right?
The point of crises is to destroy money.
Why do we need to destroy money?
Because if there's too much money in the
system, people don't have to work.
So, you have to destroy this money in
order to make people feel money is
scarce.
Okay, does that make sense?
So, why do we have wars?
Right? Why are there wars in the world
then?
Because they're fighting over scarce
resources, right?
I already told you, scarcity is a lie.
The real reason is war is meant to
destroy wealth
in order to make you think money is
valuable.
Do you understand?
You You guys play World of Warcraft
or these games, right?
Guess what, guys? World of Warcraft and
our world, there's actually no
difference. You just run around
pointlessly working hard to obtain
credits in order to buy stuff. If
credits just flew out of the sky,
because they could do that, right? They
could actually program the engine to
just print money out of nothing,
you wouldn't do nothing every day. You
wouldn't play the game.
Okay? It's only because you believe that
there's scarcity in the world and that
you must work hard to obtain wealth
that you do any work.
Do you understand this?
Okay? So, this world that we live in,
it's a complete illusion created by
central banking in order to make us work
as hard as possible.
Because the real value is not money. The
real value is the work we do.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right. Yeah? Uh
but what if the resources You said
scarcity is an illusion, right? But
uh I understand that money can be
printed infinitely, but resources such
as food and land, you know, they aren't
technically unlimited. So,
uh scarcity the scarcity still exists in
other resources. Okay, that's That's a
great question, okay? So, the question
is,
"Isn't food scarce? Because
food is a finite resource, right? Do us
a favor, okay?
Go to the garbage dump somewhere,
anywhere in Beijing, and see the amount
of food that is wasted every single day.
If food was scarce, why do we have food
waste?
Okay, so if you just do the mathematics,
what you will discover is there's enough
food to feed everyone.
Okay?
There doesn't have to be hunger and
starvation. It's an artificial crisis.
Okay, does that make sense? So, you're
right in that yeah, food's not infinite,
but it's abundant. There's a lot of it,
enough to feed people.
Okay? What about land
oil resources? You know, the reason they
go to war
Okay. All right, um so again, you guys
are stuck in the scarcity mindset.
Um and it's very convincing. So,
let's move on, okay? So, this is So,
this is something that we'll go back to
later on, okay? Because I cannot
convince you today, this morning, that
everything you believed about the world
and about yourself is wrong.
Okay, you you you're you're still stuck
there, like okay, there's scarcity. Um
and you're right, there's scarcity, but
we also live in a world of abundance.
Okay, and a lot of things that you
believe are just misconceptions about
the world.
Okay, so so we'll we'll go back there,
okay? Later on. All right? So, let's
let's let's move on, okay? So, we've
done money now, right? Now, let's do
another question. Let's do a question of
happiness.
The question for us today is what makes
us happy?
Come on. What makes you happy? How can
you live a happy life?
Okay, well, obviously,
money, right?
You have a lot of money, that's going to
make you happy. What else?
Power. Exactly, power, right? Sure.
Power.
Excuse me? Freedom. Okay, good. Freedom.
Yeah.
What else? Relationships. Relationships,
yep, sure.
You have good friends, right? Like lots
and lots of friends.
What else?
Romantic relationships. Okay, love,
right? Love. Sure. What else?
Like video games, I guess.
Vacations, okay? Lots and lots of
things, okay? What you will discover
about this list is this.
You are thinking about individual
happiness.
And this is actually unique in human
history.
If you would If you would go back in
time to find find find 5,000 years ago,
and you ask people
how can you be happy?
They would focus more on collective
happiness.
In other words, if your community were
not happy, you cannot be happy.
So, the very idea of the individual is
new in human history.
Before, we understood that if you want
to live a happy life, you need to take
care of your family. You need to take
care of your community.
For them,
for us, for almost of of human history,
happiness meant
helping others, being generous to
others.
So, for example,
let's just say that I go off
and I wander, and then I find a lot of
gold, right? I come back, and what do I
and what's the first thing I do with all
this gold? Do you guys know?
And this is like the ancient past. Dig a
hole and put them inside. Okay, yeah,
good, right? We're going to dig a hole
and put that money inside because we
want to give it to our children. That's
a modern mindset.
But what did they do before?
You
And this happened throughout every
society. If I became rich one day,
what's the first thing I would do?
Show off.
Hm? Show off.
No. Okay, so so we'll learn this, okay?
But the first thing that people did was
they had a big feast for everyone.
They spent all the money on a big feast.
Because what mattered was your
reputation within the community. What
mattered was your your generosity.
If you got rich one day, you made sure
that everyone in the community benefited
from your wealth.
Usually by holding a big feast.
And guess what, guys? This was true in
China for most of Chinese history.
Right?
If you are If you come from a Chinese
village, come become a Beijing, you open
a restaurant, you make a lot of money,
you go you go back to your village,
what's the first thing you do?
Come on, guys. Feast. You have a big
feast for everyone.
Okay, so this is in to ingrained in us,
okay? But as you say, today what we
believe is if you have a lot of money,
put it underground or put it in the
bank, okay? But back then, for most for
most of human history, we would just
spend all on a big feast.
We want everyone to share in our
happiness, and that's what made us
happy.
Okay?
I I
Any questions?
Yeah?
I was wondering
if you mentioned that
it was for reputation on some levels.
Would that count into us, you know,
individual happiness? Because
when you get rich, you care about your
reputation.
>> Okay.
Yeah, so
so you're so you're asking, isn't this
about individual reputation? And again,
I mean, this is hard, okay? But the
individual, the concept of the
individual did not exist before. We just
We just created it.
The idea that I'm a person independent
of my family, independent of my
community,
independent of the world around me,
makes no sense.
What was the worst punishment that could
be inflicted on you in the past?
Let's just say that we get in a fight, I
kill you, right? No,
like you're
They say you are no longer belong to
this world. Exactly. Banishment, exile.
Not death, right? And today, if I killed
you, the police would come, catch me,
and then kill me. But before, we didn't
do that because the worst thing that we
could do was exile you. Says, you're no
longer part of us.
You understand? So, the concept of the
individual did not exist.
Right?
Okay. So, let's move on.
All right. So, now I'm going to present
two understandings of the world, and
you're going to tell me which
understanding you think is correct. In
the first understanding,
we humans
don't have agency. We don't have really
control. Why? Because there are powerful
gods out there, okay? There are these
powerful gods like Apollo,
Dionysus.
Oh, the problem though is that
they are also controlled by other gods
that are more powerful, like, for
example, fate,
fortune.
And then there are these
really ancient gods that control the
structure of the universe. For example,
maybe anger
and pride.
So, you have absolutely no individual
agency because there's always a god
screwing with you, okay? You might get
rich, but then the god of pride looks at
you and says, "No, no, no. I need I need
to teach this mortal a lesson." So, the
god comes into me, makes me too
arrogant, and I screw up.
Okay? So, we're always being controlled
by these forces beyond our
understanding.
Okay, so that's the first worldview.
The second worldview is this.
We are synapses
that generate memories.
Okay?
We are memories. Our understanding of
the world comes from our experience.
That is controlled by synapses.
Synapses come from a combination of
DNA
and environment.
Our genes and our interaction with the
environment, our experiences.
And what this means is that
we can now have control over our own
individual fate. If you're angry, it's
because
some experience or some genes made you
angry,
and this anger becomes reinforced in
your memories. And therefore, if you do
proper therapy, if you do proper
reflection, if you do some exercises,
you can better control your anger, and
therefore control your fate. Okay? So,
in the first worldview,
there are lots and lots of gods.
They're evil, and they're random,
and we have absolutely no control over
our fate. We can only hope to get lucky
in life and not piss off the gods.
In the second worldview, we are only a
collection of our memories, and of and
we are only synapses. So, we're able to
manipulate the memories and the synapses
in a proper way, we can be free of all
problems.
We can be free of anger. We can be free
of hap- of depression.
We can be free of misery.
All right?
Let me Let me ask you this question.
Which worldview is a more accurate
reflection of reality?
The second one. Obviously the second
one, right?
Because this is
um neuroscience.
Science.
Or psychology or psychiatry. This is
what you've been taught in school.
This is what you all believe. Our entire
society is structured around this very
idea.
And what you will learn in this class is
it is completely wrong.
It is the sec- it is the first one that
is more accurate reflection of reality.
The first one gives you more
information. Gives you Gives you a more
accurate assessment of how the world
really works.
Okay?
So now, let me ask you this question.
If the first worldview,
and this is what this called we'll call
polytheism.
And polytheism, for most of human
history, was the dominant religion,
okay?
Now we live in a world where the
religion is science. Science is
basically religion.
So, why did we make this transition?
What's the benefit? If you're a powerful
person, why would you prefer the second
one as opposed to the first one? The
second one.
Why? What's the benefits to powerful
people? What What does power
want to believe the second one but not
the first one?
Uh
they can blame their failure on the old
gods.
Yeah, okay.
Um so,
the idea of individual
responsibility.
Okay?
So then, there's more control.
Okay? It's easier to control people in
the system.
Right? That's the first benefit. What
What What's the second benefit?
The second benefit is you will work
harder, right?
Because in the first system,
you're like, "You know what? I don't
need to go make a lot of money because
if I make a lot of money, the gods will
punish me
and make me pro- proud. So, I'm just
going to like enjoy life and take it
easy."
Right?
So, in the first in the second system,
"No, no, I have control over my own
life. So, I need to work hard."
Okay? So, and again, the entire point of
of the system is to make you work as
hard as possible because when you work
hard, that generates real real wealth
for the powerful people. Money doesn't
does nothing, okay? Money just
incentivizes you to work hard.
So, this exists
in order to make you work harder.
There's one more benefit. Or there's
more benefits, but but but what What
What's What's another benefit?
Okay. The other benefit is this.
Powerlessness.
It makes you powerless. Why?
This system is designed to make you
absolutely powerless. Why?
You can't control anything. Why? Uh
everything is controlled by gods and
fate. No, no, no, no. No, no, no. You
See See again, again,
this is how you're brainwashed. You
believe one makes you powerless, but not
That's not correct. Two makes you
powerless. Why?
What's the difference between one and
two? Why is it in number two you are
powerless? You're playing the uh in the
game that the
uh
who have the power wants you to Okay.
So, the problem with number two is
you are incapable of collective action.
Because you think all the source of your
problems is the individual in you and
not society.
With number one, you are capable of
collective action. And the only way to
change the world is through collective
action. Does that make sense?
This is a really important point.
Two is designed to make you think the
source of all your problems is within
you.
So, you should ignore what other people
do and think. Doesn't matter to you.
And therefore, you're incapable of
identifying with other people. You're
not capable of collective action.
You're not capable of collective action
and you feel really miserable,
what you will do is play video games
or watch porn
all day.
Okay? And that's what's happening in
society today. Yeah? But in number two,
like from experience, we would know that
you should
listen to the others' advice or, you
know, you should
take others' perspec- perspectives
and not just
So, in number two, who has authority?
Who do you listen to?
You listen to scientists, right?
Scientists.
Because this system was created by
scientists to trick you.
Okay? This system you think, "Oh, it's
science. Therefore, IT MUST BE REAL."
GUYS, LET ME GIVE you a piece of advice,
okay?
If you're ever feeling sad
and you are depressed,
what should you do?
What should you do? What have you been
taught to do?
You feel sad, you're depressed, what
should you do?
Go through nature. Hm?
Walk around. Okay, yeah. The correct
answer is walk around. But that's not
what you've been taught, right? What
have you been taught to do? Tell your
friend or parent. Okay, tell your friend
or your parent. That's That's actually
really good, right? So, walking around,
exercising,
resting, talking to a friend about your
problem, that's all really good. But
what have you been taught to do in
school?
Really. If you If you If you are feeling
really really sad, what should you do?
You should go talk to a psychiatrist,
right?
You should talk to a psychologist. And
what will he do? What will he or she do?
Okay, well,
I'm going to give you a piece of advice,
okay?
And you can test it out for yourself.
But if you're feeling sad and you are
feeling depressed and you feel you have
to talk to a psychiatrist and you do so,
I will make you a bet that the psych-
psychiatrist will make it a lot worse.
You will feel worse after talking to a
psychiatrist.
Okay?
And the reason why is the system is not
designed to cure you of any problems.
The system is to make you dependent
on authority.
You know that if you feel sad,
Well, you know what? Just go for a walk,
talk to a friend, you'll feel better
over time. But the system teaches you,
"No, if you feel sad, go talk to a
psychiatrist who will give you drugs."
It's designed to make you dependent on
authority. Yeah?
Um I want to know if like in scenario
one,
uh in world world number one, wouldn't
God also be an authority?
Like God would also be an authority.
That's actually a great question, okay?
God
is authority.
Okay. That's actually a great question.
Thank you so much. Um
so, I have to spend time to explain to
you both systems and I will do so. But
what's really important about number one
is
the gods
are
really
bad people, okay? The gods in number one
of this system, they fight all the time.
They're vengeful. They're angry. They're
proud. But because they're gods, they
can they can they can get away with it.
And that's the difference between humans
and gods. We're all the same. We're all
angry. We're all
Hm? Jealous. We all fight, okay? But the
gods can get away with it. Humans
cannot.
Gods can do hy- hubris. We cannot do
hubris.
Do you Do you understand?
So, the idea that, "Oh, the people in
power are benevolent. The people in
power are authority figures who are
after our best interest." That is a new
modern concept. Before, it was assumed
that the king is a king. Why? Because
he's favored by the gods.
It's not because he's a good person.
It's not because he's a just ruler. It's
just because the gods like him for
whatever reason. But guess what?
The gods give and the gods take.
Maybe today the king will
uh rule us, but maybe 5 years from now
he gets unlucky and the gods kill him.
Too bad. If you read Greek mythology,
and we will do so in this class, okay?
We'll go over into Greek civilization.
We'll look at Oedipus.
We'll look at Homer, the Iliad, okay?
They talk about this all the time.
Fate is something that you cannot
control. Something that happens to you.
And therefore,
you must live life to your best.
All right? So, the difference is this.
The difference is
in number one, they have a concept
called eudaimonia.
If you have no control
over your fate, if things can happen to
you tomorrow that kill you, then live
your life to the best of your ability
today.
Seize the day.
Be the best that you can be today.
And that's how you win favor from the
gods.
Eudaimonia, what we call flourishing.
The point of life is to live it to the
best of your ability.
And that's why, guess what guys, the
ancients, the Greeks, they were superior
to us.
If you read Greek literature, if you
read Greek philosophy, Plato, Homer,
Aeschylus, Euripides, they were the
best. Today, we suck. Why? Because
instead of eudaimonia, we have pleasure.
Rather than flourish
as creative people, we're like, "How do
I enjoy my life today?
How do I not feel sad?"
Okay?
So, in the first system,
even though it sounds like we have no
control, we have no agency, but it it
inspires us to live to the best of our
ability.
The second system, we're like, "Oh, you
have control complete control of your
life." It enslaves us.
Okay.
All right.
Now, let's move on to the third and
final example.
Okay. And I know this is shocking, I
know this is surprising,
but over the course of the semester, I
will give you enough evidence to
convince you that this is all true,
okay? I'm just going to set set the
structure and framework today. All
right.
Let's Let's Let's do Let's do now do
school.
GUYS,
WHY DO WE HAVE SCHOOL?
WHY ARE WE IN SCHOOL?
WHY?
Why are you here?
What?
Someplace learn and teach. Exactly,
right? Learn.
What else?
Hm?
Yeah, to get to get the degree, okay?
To get the degree.
Okay, to graduate.
What else?
Knowledge, yes.
Yeah. Hm? The power Hm? chance to
brainwash the students.
Excuse me?
I feel like you have the power
a chance to brainwash them.
Brainwashing.
Okay, guess what guys?
The correct answer is brainwashing.
Everything else is a lie.
Okay.
All right.
What do you do in school? You come to
class,
you listen to a lecture, you read books,
right? And then you And then you have to
do a test, and you have to write a
paper.
And then
And then the teacher gives you a grade.
That's how you learn, right?
Let me ask you this question then.
Throughout most of human of human
history, how do we learn?
If you want to be a doctor, what did you
do?
The answer is
experience, do it.
Right? Let me ask you this question.
Let's say you're 12 years old, you want
to be a doctor, okay? There are two
paths ahead of you. The first path is,
"You know what? I'm just putting you in
a hospital,
and you're going to learn there for like
10 years. Someone's going to mentor you.
Someone's going to You're You're going
to be that person's apprentice. Maybe
the first year all you do is like
wash the floor.
Okay? But you're going to observe the
doctor. And then eventually the doctor's
going to tell you how to
um
treat patients, okay? That's the first
system. Second system is
you go to the best school in the world.
Then you go to Harvard
for
undergraduate.
Then you go to Harvard Medical School,
the best medical school in the world.
Okay? Age 30, who's a better doctor,
number one or number two?
First one. OBVIOUSLY THE FIRST ONE,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE the second person, the person
who went to Harvard and Harvard Medical
School, did not ever work in a hospital.
You understand?
Now, let me ask you another question.
In the first system,
do you have to be really really smart to
be a good doctor?
No. You don't, actually.
Anyone can be a doctor in the first
system.
Anyone.
We human beings are all born the
capacity to learn anything if you wanted
to learn it, right?
You'll be an engineer, you'll be a
lawyer, if you want to be a doctor,
you'll be a scientist, you'll be
anything, okay? Just go find a mentor
who can teach you how to do so. And I I
guarantee you that you will learn how to
do it well.
And anyone can do this.
But instead, we have a system
in which
we tell students, "You're smart, you're
stupid." Smart students go to good
schools and good universities, and they
get good jobs. Stupid students go wash
dishes.
Okay? And that was not true for most of
human history. It's true today, but
throughout most of of human history, if
you wanted to go learn something, all
you had to do
was go find a teacher.
And that teacher would teach you, and
then you would learn it.
Right?
So, school is not is not a place
to
teach you how to learn. A school doesn't
teach you knowledge, it doesn't do that.
A school is a place that brainwashes
you.
Okay? Now, the question then is,
what does it brainwash you in?
Why would it brainwash you?
Okay. All right, to answer that,
I'm going to give you some history,
okay? We We will do a lot of history in
this class.
But I'm going to tell you the three
societies that first introduced
mandatory
free
public schooling
in the world, okay?
The first is called Sparta.
Okay? Sparta was a small city-state in
Greece, like three, four thousand years
ago, three thousand years ago.
And they had a new system in which
children as early as five or six years
old, they were put into a school.
And in the school, they were being led
by older kids who were like nine or 10.
Okay?
That's Sparta.
The second society
was called the Aztecs.
Aztecs.
And they also provided free compulsory
education to all its children.
Really good, right?
And the third society is called Prussia.
And actually Prussia is a system that
everyone uses today.
Do you guys know any history? Okay? What
is common about all three societies?
Sparta, Aztecs, and Prussia.
Hm?
What is common to all three?
Okay.
War.
All three societies are fundamentally
war societies
dedicated to defeating their neighbors.
Sparta was
one of thousands of city-states in
Greece.
The only society of these thousands that
had compulsory education. Why? Because
Sparta was first and foremost engaged in
war making. Sparta, you've heard of
Spartans, right? It's the Spartan
warrior.
Okay?
The Aztecs
were the greatest war society in Central
America
before the arrival of Europeans.
They defeated everyone. They were
engaged in war.
They also did a lot of human sacrifice
as well.
Okay, we learn about the Aztecs later
on.
Prussia.
The Prussians, the greatest military in
Europe for centuries.
They were engaged in war making as well.
Okay, do you understand this?
Why do we have schools is because
schools
are really good
at preparing people for war.
Why?
Excuse me?
Um What is What is Why Why Let me ask
you this question. Why did not did not
did not have schools before?
Why is it that people were like, "We
don't want schools." Why?
Again,
the Sparta, Aztecs, and Prussia were the
few societies that had free public
schooling.
Why didn't other societies just copy
them?
Why?
Okay, let me ask you this question.
Let's just say you're a mother or
father. What's the And you have a child,
right? What's the worst thing that could
happen in your life?
Hm? No parents?
No, no. Your mother or your father. You
You have a child, right? What's the
worst thing that can happen
to you in your life?
Your child is taken away from you,
right? Oh.
What does school do?
School is designed to take your child
away from you.
Okay?
Let me ask you this question.
If school was about learning, why don't
parents and children go to school
together?
Yeah, why not? Why? Because they have to
work.
To make money
to survive.
Because parents have to work to survive,
right? There's actually a better reason
why.
School is for us is to socialize and
also have two people to do something.
Okay, it's about brainwashing, right?
Because how do you brainwash someone?
Right?
If you're with your parent, are you
going to be brainwashed? No. No, cuz you
feel loved. You feel secure. Your
parents are going to protect you. You
can ask your parent, "Hey, is this
teacher is is he or she lying to me?"
And the parent might say, "Yeah, she's
he's lying to you, okay?"
It's only because you've been taken away
from your from your parent
But
that you are now willing to be
brainwashed. Why? Because what happens
if you if you leave your parents, how do
you feel?
How do you feel? Insecure.
Hm?
Insecure.
Yeah, exactly, right? Insecure. You're
anxious. You're afraid.
Do you understand? You've lost your
parent. You're four, you're five, you're
six years old. You've lost your parent.
You feel really insecure.
So, who do you trust?
Your teacher. Your teacher. Whatever
your teacher says is now correct. But
the
whatever our parents are also
brainwashed like
cuz they they went to school before when
they were in school. Yeah, yeah, okay.
That's that's a good point, okay? Aren't
our brain parents brainwashed as well?
Um
that's correct. Your parents are
brainwashed. But what I'm saying is when
a parent is with a child, the child
feels secure. And And if you're secure,
you're much more willing to disobey
authority. You're much willing to ask
questions. You're much willing to think
for yourself because you feel secure.
Because your parent is there to protect
you. But if you take the parent away,
you can't do that. You must be now rely
on the teacher who can now brainwash
you.
Okay? So, are you brainwashing us?
Am I brainwashing you?
Okay. I think it's the dark truth. Okay.
All right. Okay. So, the question is, am
I brainwashing you? Okay, that's a good
question. And it's a fair question.
And again,
that's why I tell you this, okay? You
have the capacity to ask me questions.
You have the capacity to challenge me.
You have the capacity to think for
yourself.
Okay? So, so all I'm saying is, hear me
out,
ask me questions, and then think for
yourself whether or not I make sense.
Because the difference between my class
and other classes is like I don't test
you,
right? I don't give you grades. It's a
pass fail class.
You can actually choose to say, "You
know what? This is nonsense. I don't
want to listen anymore."
I can't I can't stop you.
Okay? But in school, guess what happens
if you don't go to come to school?
Your parents get arrested.
All right?
Do you understand? That's the
difference.
It's your choice whether or not to pay
attention or not.
All right. So, another question is,
okay,
if schools are designed to brainwash
you, what are they brainwashing you in?
What they they designed to brainwash you
to believe a concept
called the nation state.
The nation state.
The school is designed to brainwash you
to think the nation state exists. It is
a person, mother China. You must love
this person. You must be willing to
sacrifice yourself for this person. You
must willing to be willing to dedicate
yourself to this person because it is
mother China.
And how do we brainwash you? We teach
you language, right?
We teach you history. We teach you
geography.
We teach you all this to make you
believe that the nation state, mother
China, the United States, France, they
all exist. But guess what? Throughout
most of human history,
it was absurd
to think the nation state existed.
Okay? Before, you didn't say, "I'm
Chinese." Before you say, "I'm a
Beijinger."
Or I'm from Haidian.
Or I'm from Chaoyang, right? Because
that makes more sense.
You're from a place where you know the
people.
But now, because of the nation state,
you are forced to believe that you are
the same person as someone from Yunnan,
Tibet, Guangxi, even though guess what,
guys? You have absolutely nothing in
common. Okay? But you're all Chinese.
And that's what school is designed to
do. School is designed to implant in you
a false memory
of a nation state.
Okay? That's what history is. History is
the false memory of a nation state.
And it hap-
And
that's why you're all forced to go to
school.
Okay?
Okay, maybe like they also want you to
just think about degrees and work as a
normal person, not to create a new
business or be resourceful. Yeah. So, so
yeah, so
the point of school is to serve the
nation state. Do you understand? Oh.
Right? Does that make sense? If you
believe in the nation state, if you
believe in mother China, then you must
serve her. You must obey her. You must
fight for her. You must die for her.
Okay? So, the the idea of the nation
state was created in order to make you
obedient to authority.
And it works very effectively.
Yeah?
I was just wondering if this only works
out in
the Chinese context like
All countries. All countries are nation
states, okay? So, I I mean like I'm not
saying China is different from other
places. China is exactly the same as
other places. Okay? What you will learn
in this class is, how do we get to this
place? Because again, the three things
that we learn, okay? Money,
the individual,
the nation state.
These are all ideas and concepts beyond
the human experience.
If you try to work this out from first
principles, if you try to figure this
out by yourself, you couldn't do it. You
have to be brainwashed into believing
these three things. If someone from the
past, maybe a thousand years ago, were
to come today and you you would explain
the concept of money, individual, and
nation state, the person would be like,
"Wait a minute here.
This means that
you're all slaves."
Okay?
So, another question then is,
where do we get these three concepts
from?
What you will learn in this class is
these three concepts come from a
revolution
in human thought called monotheism.
The one true God.
This idea, monotheism,
forever changed the course of human
history. And it gave us these concepts
of money, individual, and nation state.
Monotheism is such a powerful idea
that it turned nothing into everything.
Okay? That's what you will learn in this
class.
We will learn about monotheism. We will
discover how it created money,
individual, and the nation state. And it
basically created the world that we live
in today.
Okay?
All right.
Any questions?
Is Is Christianity like
monotheism?
Excuse me?
Christianity is like monotheism. Okay,
yeah. So, there are three great
monotheistic religions, right? Judaism,
Christianity,
and Islam.
What I will show you later on is it's
basically the same religion.
Yeah. All right.
Okay, so I I I I don't want to give you
too much information, okay? Because
there's a lot to process. But I want you
guys to learn the concepts. Money,
individual, and nation state are all
powerful concepts that are embedded into
everyday life. You cannot escape it.
Okay, you've been brainwashed into
thinking that they all exist when in
fact they don't actually they don't
actually don't exist.
And And that's how power works. What
power is, okay?
What power truly is
is what I call
alchemy.
Alchemy
throughout human history
was the pursuit of turning lead into
gold.
Okay? Lead into gold.
Okay?
Nothing
into everything.
That's what alchemy was.
And
maybe in science class you're taught
that alchemy is this fake science. It's
a pseudo science. And it did not work.
What What What What you will learn in
this class is we achieved alchemy.
Okay? We turned nothing into everything.
We turned lead into gold. Or that's what
power is.
Power is the capacity to turn nothing
into everything. Power is the capacity
to make you believe that money is
valuable.
That the individual can lead to
happiness.
That the nation-state exists. That's
what power is.
Okay? And as a result,
today we live extremely miserable
lives.
Okay?
So you So you've been taught to think
that, "Oh,
life just gets better and better." What
you will learn in this class is actually
um
Nope, okay?
And what's What's really important is
you will also learn in this class that
this was an accident.
Okay? This this is an accident.
It's an accident of the human
imagination.
It's because we didn't know what we were
doing that we created this system.
So you What you will also learn is that
if you're able to control the human
imagination,
you can use it to create a new system
that allows for eudaimonia,
or the flourishing
of the human intellect.
Okay?
All right.
Any questions?
Okay. So, um that's it for
uh
today. Okay? I'll see you guys
next class.